we just saw how to use fourier tail
bounds to construct
fractional prgs and i want to also
mention
that you can use random restriction
lemmas
if you can prove that the family of
functions that you want to fool
some somehow simplifies under a p random
restriction
then you can use this itself in order to
construct a fractional prg
um and in fact i don't have any
applications for this to give but i
think it's an interesting thing to know
if you want to you know if at any time
you wanted to come up with a
pseudo-random generator and you
you felt like it's easy to show that
your family
simplifies under a truly random
restriction
so what's a p random restriction it's
just a
random variable over whoops
that's not good
yeah so it's a it's a random variable
that takes minus one one star to the n
values and we think of the stars as the
you know the variables that we allow
we leave alive and the ones and minus
ones are
the restricted variables and
we leave a variable alive with
probability p
and it's a uniform bit otherwise
and a generic random restriction lemma
or a switching
lemma type statement we'll say that
all the functions in this family that i
care about
simplify with high probability under
random restriction
and for the purposes of pseudorandom
generators you should think of simplify
as and we can fool them easily
so for example their degree drops or you
know some somehow their l1
fourier bounds drop that we can use
basic generators to fool
this restricted function and
this is a general method to construct
pseudonym generators
which is to de-randomize this statement
try to de-randomize this statement and
come up with the pseudorandom
restriction lemma
and this is essentially this
anti-vectors and
framework where but
all of the applications that we know of
are not very generic the randomization
itself
looks into the proof of the restriction
lemma for the family and tries to
show that the same proof uh will go
through
using a pseudorandom restriction
by using further properties from the
family and what i will show
is that you don't need to necessarily do
this unless
you know if if you are willing to lose a
little bit in this parameters
if you're willing to pay for this
reduction from fprg to prgs that we had
and the the trick is kind of simple so
let's just formalize what we mean by
this random restriction lemma so let's
say that we actually have a generate
generator
that fools the restricted function with
high probability over the restriction
and this is a p random restriction and
it will be helpful to think of the
restriction as just a pair
uh one is a set which is a set of a
subset of the variables where
we pick each of the variables with
probability p so these are the alive
variables
and we have a uniform distribution
over the restricted variables outside of
a
okay and we will make the following
definition so we will define
f sub p of x to be
the expected you know so this
here we have f the restricted function
that the restriction gives us
so the restricted function on input x
will plug in the x values on the
live indices and it will plug in the
unit for outside
so we will define this f sub p to be
just the expectation of all of these
restrictions of f right so this is some
real valued
function why do we do this
it's because it has the following nice
property so first of all
if i take the expected value
if i look at f of 0 which is the
expectation of f it's basically
the same as taking this and taking its
expectation over the uniform
distribution
when x is uniform right because
it doesn't matter what the set a is if
i'm plugging in uniform here i have
uniform in a
in uniform a complement so i just get
the expectation
so f of 0 is equal to this quantity
where i'm now
it's it's close to this quantity why
because
where instead of uniform plugging in
this
g why is that because it's because
this f is a restriction of the
original function and i know that with
high
probability over a and u g
fools this restriction so i can replace
the uniform with g
sub a so these two expectations are
close to each other
by the restriction lemma right so i'm
being sloppy i'm just talking about high
probability etc
but let's let's do that
and the next thing is you can actually
look at this
expectation here so the input in fact is
a random vector and it has a product
distribution
each of its coordinates is either x i
or a uniform distribution and we it's
going to be equal to x i with
probability p
so this function is nothing but f
evaluated at p times
x by multi-linearity
right does that make sense so this
function that we defined
is just some expectation over this
random vector which each of its
coordinates is
an expectation p times x i so f p of x
is just
f of p x now
combining the two we are done so what we
have shown is that f
of 0 which is this guy is close
to to this quantity which is really
by this definition it's f of p times g
right so this x is just the g i'm
plugging in
g for this equation so what we have
shown is that f of 0 is close to
expectation
over g of f of p times g so what this
says is that p
times g is a fractional prg
for the family f okay
so here your one question do you see
here i'm giving the g
full f row without knowing row right
exactly with that without knowing i mean
with high probability over row g full
stroke
f sub row does that make sense
yeah well in some sense you're
using even something weaker you're using
the fact that the
your generator falls the average of
expectation
exactly so and this is something that's
already used in
uh some applications of this iteration
method also right so
so sometimes it's it helps to fool the
expected
expected restriction instead of just
showing that with high probability
we can fool the restriction function and
here we are
we could ideally use that to our
advantage in our
random restriction level so maybe uh
we can fool this expected function um
easier but but yes so you could
formalize it in different ways but i
think the general
uh thing that's interesting is that we
didn't need to look at the family f
so as long as you can show a truly
random restriction
uh simplifies the family then you get
some prga
i guess and i can see that this p times
g
i was just finding out that like in some
sense g
is still on n bits right
yes it's trees on it and it's like you
know usually when we apply television
framework
you get to design something only on p
times n
bits
and it's it's true but most of the
constructions you know we we say that
like we say that like ky's independence
fools it so you can do k y's over n bits
instead of uh the the p n bits but i i
see your point yes so we have
we are treating it as a function over
and it's right now
like when you in one of our papers when
we used shrinkage
to build prgs were using extractors so
you needed to know the order
and do some other stuff exactly and
and in fact you can't use what i just
said for
getting any prgs in that framework in
the first place like as soon as p
is uh not very small we don't get
anything
uh you know p is not very large when we
then we don't get very interesting
things because
if you remember the reduction from fprgs
to prgs
will have this one over p squared in the
seed length
which kills us in a lot of applications
if your
random restriction is very aggressive
then it just doesn't
give us anything interesting so so it
seems that it's still there open
whether we like the anti-vigor zone for
example framework
like when we work hard and prove all
these things then we usually get the one
over p dependence
exactly so this we have a square loss
here
as as opposed to the i type jersey so
the loss
in the seed length of applying repeated
pseudorandom restrictions
is usually just roughly one over p
as opposed to here we are taking this
random walk that needs one over p
squared steps and that's because this is
p squared noticeable this uh fractional
ph
that's a very good point so there is a
gap um
you know if if you can de-randomize the
restriction lemma
you should do that first if you can't
then you can hope that maybe
this p squared is okay but these are
hopes that maybe with we
like uh there's a generic way
because so that's maybe was my point
that you are
relying on a weaker um assumption on the
class
that you fool the average if you maybe
know that you can fool a random
restriction maybe
this stronger assumption maybe i yeah i
don't see how to use it but
it could be potential that if you know
how to do that then you could
potentially get the one over per
there is a one over p squared lower
bound
because all boolean functions have uh
l1a be bound for one over square root
yes that's actually a good point so
so shakhar is pointing out that there is
the lower bound on the
this random walk which is one over p
squared because all boolean functions
satisfy
l one a b with square root n
yeah that's a good point
but but maybe there is a you know there
is some other way of
doing this so so if you imagine
like applying the random restriction you
can also think of it as
it's like a degenerated uh
fractional prg where for at each step
some of the coordinates are zero and
some are become either one or minus one
all right so that's obviously you need
that too many too much randomness in
order to
implement it so but right yeah
yeah and you know there's also this
question of what if you
don't go all the way with this random
walk so maybe you can
stop it early and show that now this
family simplifies enough that
you can fool it in some other ways so
there's a
there's you know questions that you can
ask about so how can you can you do a
hybrid between the random walk and
other ideas which i'm not sure what the
answers are
so good questions
okay um
and so let me discuss some further
directions and
some more recent developments and this
this area
um so again so what we showed is that if
you have
a bound of b to the k on all the case
level fourier coefficients
of uh l one bound and the fourier
coefficients of the family
then you can get a prg that has seed
length roughly one over
b squared fully log n over epsilon
and l1 k here is just the sum of the
absolute values of the kth level
coefficient
so in particular for any family that you
have b that's probably log n you get a
poly login seed length prg out of this
and the question is well can we use this
to get prgs for interesting families
like degree d
f2 polynomials where d becomes
you know where we reach the barrier for
the current state of the art so we know
viola's generator has seat length
t times two to the t that's the state of
the art and this
completely trivializes when d is equal
to log n so can we hope
to use this to to get something better
um and
you know at least we conjecture that for
f two polynomials you
have some l l1 bound that's
that's exponential where b is just
exponential in d
and this would at least give us some
matching generator for violas uh
generators in in terms of seed length
and you know so what we can prove
for f2 polynomials is that the kth level
l1
fourier coefficients and one norm of the
fourier coefficient
is bounded by a quantity that's like k
times two to the three d
to the k and you can see that this is
problematic
uh for for our application because this
k is growing so you don't have like just
this one b
that's bounded for all of the levels
but we do manage in another work to to
bound the first level by something
reasonable that's o of t
so this is our current understanding of
the fourier coefficients of
f2 polynomials and
it is an interesting question to try to
improve this
this bound and
one way to try to improve on this this
work is to
say well we couldn't prove
very good bounds for all levels of f2
polynomials but what if we could
prove it for only some levels and
can we use this to construct a
pseudorandom generator so is this is it
necessary that we need this bound on all
the levels
and we did study this question in a
joint work with
ishan shaharan avishai where we showed
that only the second level
is already sufficient so having a bound
on the only this n choose two fourier
coefficients at the second level
showing that they sum up to at most some
quantity t
we can construct a pseudorandom
generator out of this
that has seed length polynomial in t and
log n
and i'm hiding the dependence on epsilon
because it's not good
it's it's polynomial it's not
logarithmic in epsom
and and the idea here is uh so we build
on this work of uh
ranraz and avishai uh where they
they use this kind of this random walk
idea to give a separation between
bqp and ph
but the general idea here is that the
higher moments of a multivariate
gaussian
are controlled by its variances and
covariances
and you can construct an mvg that has
these nice
covariances and variances using very few
truly samples from a gaussian
independent and you use balanced
constructions of good balance codes
uh to do this dimension reduction and
then you discretize this whole
construction uh
this is very high level and hand wavy
but that's that's as much as
i'm gonna talk about this construction
maybe
maybe something that's interesting that
epsilon bass are also entering the
picture but in a different way for
constructing these balance codes so
that's that's very that's very true yeah
so our best constructions of these
balance codes are the optimum
constructions we know for
epsilon biased distributions
and they somehow come into this picture
again but in now
in the construction of a how to
low-dimensionally sample this
mvg
okay but this is interesting because
if you want to break the log
log barrier for polynomials
this new result shows that all that's
you need is to prove
that the second level fourier
coefficient of
an f and f2 polynomial are bounded by
some polynomial in d
in fact we conjecture that the bounds
should be d squared
so if you could prove this then you get
a prg for
polynomial f2 polynomials of degree log
n and you can
read about importance of this other than
just in
purpose of in terms of prgs in a very
good
survey that viola has written
but i have written this one over epsilon
here
in red because so as compared to the
original
random walks idea that we had we got
probably log one over epsilon dependence
in the seed length but
this construction gets only polynomial
and one over epsilon
but we use a much weaker assumption
instead of all levels we only have
second level three coefficient bounds
and this fresh out of the oven uh
new work of chatter padilla ital from
pretty much
last week gives a hybrid in between
these two worlds
right so they actually answer the
question that
can we construct an fprg from some level
k
by showing that if you had a bound on
the level k
for your coefficients l one bound and
the level k
then you can get better error dependence
so the larger the k
the better this dependence of seed
length and epsilon becomes
so it's very interesting and to make it
more interesting
they they show how to
construct these prgs using a weaker
assumption than an l1 bound
so in particular instead of taking the
sum of the absolute values of the
fourier coefficients
so we define mk to be the maximum of
just writing the sum of the expansion of
the
the function at level k and then taking
the absolute value
okay this is potentially much
easier to prove bounds for because you
can have all sorts of cancellations
happening before you take the absolute
value
so this is obviously mk of f is bounded
by
l1k of f but this could potentially be
much smaller
and what this new paper shows
is that if there's some k so this k has
to be at least
three and if you can prove that mk of f
is at most b to the k then you can
construct a fractional prg of seed
length k log n
and this will be a p noticeable
fractional prg where p is absolute on to
the 2 over k b squared so
you can see that
better and you can get a better prg out
of this
by by plugging it into the polarizing
random walks
um and in fact they show that you can
improve the seed length of this
fractional prg to
log log n plus log k over epsilon if
if you had a bound on the l1 norm but on
the lower levels
so we still are not assuming a bound on
all levels we are saying that all of the
tailbones we have are up to level k and
uh
and level k we only have this without
the absolute value bound
so it's very interesting
and combining it with the random walks
construction it gives you a prg with
seed length
1 over epsilon so the dependence on
epsilon will be something like 1 over
epsilon to the 2 over k minus 2. so if
you take k to be really large the
dependence is really small
on epsilon okay
and obviously it's going to be great to
hear it's a new
new work and i'm excited to hear the the
authors to present it but i i thought
that i would spend a little bit of time
and
present what i understood out of this
proof
so it's a warm-up preparing you for the
actual talk that they will give
so that as you could already see
probably from the
the seed length this is already telling
what the generator is going to look like
we
started to talk by mentioning a simple
generator that has this seed length
which is
ky's independence and
the good news is that the construction
is going to be
basically multiplying a k
wise independent distribution by some
value a
right so very similar to the previous
constructions that we
discussed in this time so
we will discuss what this parameter a
should be
later in the calculations
so our goal is to show that this
pseudorandom distribution a random
variable
x fools any function f in the family
and we want to use this bound that we
have but we only have it for
some level k
well we have this k minus one wise
independence
and that suggests that we should sort of
treat the fourier coefficient based on
their size being less than k or greater
than or equal to k because things that
are less than k will just vanish
when you have a k minus 1 y's
independent distribution over a minus
a to the n the bias of all of these
things are going to be zero
and all we are left to do is to try to
bound the second term
which is the expectation of the
the tail the above k tail of the free
expansion of
f applied to this random variable
x okay so that's our goal now so
that's this is the only error term of
this generator
and the key claim is that you can
actually bound this
by the following quantity it's a over 1
minus
a to the k times m sub k of the family
f and this is quite interesting because
on the left we have
a quantity that all of the levels above
k appear
but on the right we have a bound on that
involves only level k
for your coefficients of f and
clearly this is prob this is not true if
uh i wrote lowercase f
inside here so the whole idea is to try
to use the fact that the family f
is closed under restrictions and we have
a bound
on all the restrictions or variations of
f
okay and if we could prove this claim
then
you can see that if you pick a to be
something like epsilon to the 1 over k
over b then this will allow us to bound
this term which was our error term
by epsilon
good so how do we prove this claim
so the idea is that to make this the
following key definition
uh we will define a single variate
real function g g of t where g of t
is just equal to f of t times x
so let's say that let's assume that x is
a vector that's fixed
and we define g of t to be f of t times
x
and the trick is going to be to take
derivatives of this
function g
there's two important observations
so the first one is if i take
the kth derivative of g
you can think of the definition so you
can look at the fourier expansion of
f at tx so all of the monomials of
degree less than
k will disappear because they have a t
to the
some power less than k by them
right because we have t times x and
if you evaluate it at zero so whatever
terms you get from the fourier
coefficients that are of higher level
they also will also vanish because they
will have a surviving
variable t in them so you had some t
to the k plus one and you took k
derivatives t still survives so when you
plug in zero they also vanish
so the case derivative of g
evaluated as 0 is exactly k factorials
times the case level fourier expansion
of
f evaluated at x okay
so this is one important
and the the main
technical observation in this new paper
is to
use a taylor's theorem approximation
and uh so we will write uh
the taylor expansion on g of one
so what we want to evaluate what g of
one is in terms of its derivatives
and why do we care about g of one
because g of one is exactly
f of x so that's the function that we
care about
and the taylor theorem gives us tells us
that g of one which is f of x
is the sum over all of the
k is derivatives up to level k minus 1
evaluates that 0 divided by i factorial
plus an error term and that the error
term is the kth derivative of g
evaluated at sum s we don't know what s
is but we know
that it's something between 0 and 1.
but what's cool here is that by the
first observation
all of these terms are exactly the
the fourier expansion of f up to level
k minus one so we know that on the left
we have f of x
on the right we have all of the up to
level k
so this term must be all of the
you know large tail of f free expansion
of it
so even though we don't know what s is
we know that the case derivative of g
evaluated at s divided by k factorial
is exactly this quantity the expectation
of which we want to bound remember
so we want to bound the expected value
of
this quantity exactly
and okay so this part will be a little
bit
hand wavy but so let's do it so i will
define
a new function h of t which is
essentially f of s times x plus
t times 1 minus a times x and think of
this
this way so s is this this uh this
point you know that's coming from the
approximation
and i'm making sure that this this
vector
still stays inside of the solid cube
right
because x is taking values in a minus a
so i'm i'm making sure that i don't step
outside
and the idea will be that if you take
the kth derivative of this new function
h and evaluate it at zero by the chain
rule
you can you get basically one minus a to
the number of times you
took the derivative which is one minus a
to the k
uh and you plug in zero so that the t
part vanishes so you get just
kth derivative at s okay so this is now
becoming related to this quantity that
we cared about
and finally the the final
key observation is that because of the
way
h is defined you can think of it as some
complex combination
of functions in the family so
restrictions of f
because of the way this is defined you
can do this random variable trick again
and write h as a convex hall of
f the family f and what this
allows us to do is to to
use this uh to this kth level bound
because we know
that h k is uh this gk
of s like you so we know we know that
uh we can use this this case level
bounds on mk
and we have this a to the k com so so
for each functions that appear in the
convex hull we apply this mk bound
uh and we also have this normalizing
parameter a to the k because it's coming
from
the k if level fourier coefficients are
all have this a to the k normalizing
factor coming out of it because
x was a minus a to the n variable
and that's how you can bound this kth
derivative evaluated but at zero
a quantity that's now related to empty
wasn't clear but
you know i'm just trying to give
some sort of entry and this allows us to
bound gk of s you combine these two you
get a bound on gk of s
being bounded by exactly a over
one minus a to the k and
this f the quantity that we wanted to
bound in the expectation is just that
divided by k
factorial so that proves the claim that
we wanted to prove
um so it's a it's a very elegant and
a nice idea i recommend you to
to look up this new paper it's it's on
uh
it's available in archive at least i i
think that maybe the ecc is not
updated in summary
what we did during this talk was we
defined
a new object called the fractional prg
which was just simply a random variable
that takes values
inside of the boolean cube a solid
boolean cube we showed how to use it to
construct a prg
and we showed that we can construct
these
fractional prgs from assumptions on
fourier tails
of the the boolean the boolean function
family that we have at hand
and these were quite good fractional
prg's i would give them
maybe three stars they're not as good as
you want it they're not like
log n over epsilon they're pretty good
um
and later we showed that if you had only
level two bounds you get
pretty decent fprgs maybe if you care
about epsilon
not very good and this new
this new paper shows that if you had kth
level bounds for some
large k then you can get much better
dependence maybe not logarithmic but
you know the the larger the k the better
and let me end by mentioning some open
problems so
obviously one of the problems that i
care about is going to be to prove this
bound on the second level fourier
coefficients and l1 bounds which would
give you
a prg for f2 polynomials and
and in fact it would give us uh the
first non-trivial prgs
for for ac 0 with parity it would give
us logarithmic seed length where
ac 0 with parity if you combine it with
rasmuro's
smolensky type approximation by low
degree polynomials
and motivated by this new work of uh
chateau patiel
uh we they conjecture that
you can bound the case level of f2
polynomials by some
if you can bound it by some quantity
that's 2 to the little o of d
then even if you do this for k equal to
3 then you do break the log n barrier
you don't get poly logarithmic seedling
but you do get a non-trivial prg for
degree log n f f2 polynomials and i want
to mention also that
because this new prg doesn't require a
bound on all levels
even the current bounds that we had
proved on the tail
tail of the degree d polynomials suffice
to
plug it into this construction and get a
prg that's comparable to vols
construction
so it's it it is something interesting
it's a new prg for f2 polynomials and
another interesting fact about trying to
bound mk
instead of the l1 uh bound of the three
or coefficients is that
this is provably related to proving
correlation bounds with
xor of several copies of majority so we
already know that f2 polynomials have
correlation roughly d over root n
with one copy of majority and
if you could prove an xor lemma for this
kind of correlation bound
then you would get a bound for mk of f
and in a in a recent paper we had
some method of proving these kind of
bounds
correlation bounds for majority like xor
lemmas for majority
um but the the numerator so we show that
the
you know that we do get this root n to
the k
but somehow the numerator is not good
enough for getting the correlation
bounds that are good enough for
prg so one open problem is to maybe try
to see that
if the techniques we had in this paper
can be
improved to get this up this better
bounce on the
mk of f um and that's all i had uh
please ask if you have any questions
[Music]
thank you thank you
any questions
that that's a good point so shahar is
pointing out that even bounds on
m2 are open for polynomials so we
currently have
some bounds but they're not uh you know
they have really bad dependence on the
degree
so um and
another nice open problem is if you
could
come up with a prg using m2 as i
mentioned that this new paper
uses bounds on mk
but k has to be at least three
so somehow we have a prg if you use l
one bounds at level two
we have a prg if you have
this mk bounce for levels above
three and we don't even know how to
prove m
good m2 bounce which would still not
necessarily we don't know if it would
give a prg
it's a very good point and in fact i
think if you
so if you can prove this something like
t
over root n to the k correlation bound
then you get uh
oh wait
okay so shahar has another point that so
we don't know if it's
true or not but it is possible that
uh we could make the c-h-a-t
paper which is the the one that's based
on uh the ras tall
work to make it work from m2 so that's
another direction to
to consider so currently we use
absolute values but we don't know if it
it would also go through from
from just without the absolute values
so so plenty of directions and
of course so we have so far mostly
focused on f2 polynomials but
you know if you find other applications
it would be very
is exciting does
is there an approach that unifies
these constructions with to also get you
um prgs for
half spaces or ltfs
like uh i get this this approach
intuitively it seems like it's related
to l1 norm of the fourier
it's related to f1 by spaces l1 norms of
fourier coefficients
um which i guess
it wouldn't yeah it wouldn't be suitable
is there some approach that
unifies the
like what is the construction
the construction of uh prg's for npfs
one is a white independent but is there
also something based on random
restriction
so you you can show some sort of
simplifications on the random
restrictions but
i i don't think that they're strong
enough
for using it in this framework
so like this the probability of the
restriction
the simplification happening is is
rather
not happening it's rather large so so it
won't be strong enough for
for improving this country but it's a
very good question so
is there some sort of
[Music]
way to to combine these two worlds
i mean uh there's a different kind of
fractional prg for
ltfs and polynomial threshold functions
so they're easier to fool in the
gaussian space
that's that is correct right so so the
so there there is a
we have better seed length generators
known for
things like polytopes if you care about
only this kind of
gaussian generators and so on that's
that's great
right but we don't know how to use them
to get boolean generators
exactly so the the current constructions
for booleans like the best ones still
use invariance principles and such
oh
any other questions comments
um so this is a at some point you find
fb effect
that looked exactly like the uh
zero operator it's exactly that right
stereo operator
yes yes that's that's true um so in fact
uh
you know so and and some other works
when you have
uh a bound on the free fourier tail so
one one thing to do is to
to do this p random restriction and the
expansion
and the expectation will just have this
key to the
size of s coming out and and that's sort
of what people
would exploit in showing that with high
probability you have simplification
of some sort so l one bounds so
for example the the pseudo-random
generators were
bounded with uh branching programs
in the unordered case uses these argue
arguments
but we had to somehow argue that larger
fourier coefficient bounds by looking at
the construct
the properties of the branching program
and say that if the lower
levels drop then the higher levels also
drop and
things like that but this sort of allows
the randomizing it by just
doing the expectation and the giving of
fprg
if if that made any sense this
explanation but sort of
yeah so previously these things would
come up but then you had to sort of
de-randomize it
and look at the family to see
simplification
any other questions
okay uh yeah there are no questions
let's thank that
thank you
yeah thanks everyone for uh coming up to
coming to the talks
uh this was all the talks we had planned
for the series
uh video i mean you want to continue the
series but also there's a lot of
programs starting at simon's
right now but we're debating whether to
continue the series or not
there's clearly a lot of works exciting
things happening in this area
yeah so i'll keep you posted if you do
plan to continue with it send to the
will email once more to the same mailing
list that we had
thanks everyone for the series
thanks again for organizing this uh
lecture series